my name is francois pomare
and i'm a director of research at the
national center for scientific research
in paris
and i'm also adjunct professor
basically counselor advisor to the
institute of language and culture
studies from the royal university of
buda
how did i get there
well i've been working for almost now
35 years in the himalayas
i did my m.a in ladakh
and then i got this wonderful
opportunity to go to bhutan through a
contact
and i thought i would be going for a
month or two so i went with a gin and my
sleeping bag
and 32 years later i'm still there so i
guess this is a long life commitment
at the beginning partnership was
extremely difficult because the
even idea of research as a western idea
was not understood at all and
anthropology was not even existing
so it was very difficult so i did my own
research
while working for the government of
bhutan
and
in tourism and education
and then
slowly slowly it opened
and i now partner completely
with the
institute for language and cultural
studies of the university of bhutan and
i believe in partnership completely
it's my
really my aspiration
is to be useful to help
in my little way the chinese to come
very strong in anthropology and history
about their own culture on the
international scene
and the bhutanese have a great advantage
because education is in english
so their level of english is good
already
the royal university of bhutan is a
collection
of
a federation of colleges about 10
colleges
which are spread out in the whole of the
country so we have a lot of
communication problems
but they chose this model in order to
encourage the development of the local
communities
so if you have a university in local
rural communities it helps the people to
get
a
partnership to get business opportunity
and so on so that was designed for that
the university was created officially
as a federation in 2003 by world charter
and
it has
different
colleges in
arts business
technology
and mathematics physics
and
medical science
but um
the
biggest of the problems is really
communication because internet
communication are still a problem
and so we spend a lot of time traveling
from one place to timpu which is a main
the administration is
now the ilcs institute of language and
culture study was created in 1963
but not under this name by the third
king
and dingo cancer rinpoche
as a way to preserve culture and
language
it was very very monastic in its
approach at the beginning and slowly
over the years it has completely changed
and now it has become
a full-fledged college of the royal
university of bhutan
and it has been shifted from its
previous location which was in temple
and too small
to a very remote area of south of
tungsten central bhutan where there was
nothing
and that literally
cut down the bushes made the road and
now it's a huge campus
we have about
in terms of
space
and we have about 700 students now
and we have a new
uh completely new curriculum
which incorporate a lot of western
science like anthropology cultural
studies
but it has retained
its
traditional
classes like philosophy poetry and also
dances etiquette which is so important
in buddha protocol etiquette whatever
you call it
so it's a absolutely amazing place and
it's a mix it really symbolizes buddha
in that way it's a mix between
our tradition and extremely
modern
contemporary
outlook
you